just made songs about it yeah yeah we'd
all be behind you make bangers as long
as you're making bangers like we got
into Jesus for a little bit because of
one of his bangers yeah Jesus did walk
women danced to a song Calling them gold
digging
[Music]
to dance again
make bangers Kanye get off
get off her yeah
so not pissed off at all you didn't dare
I was just like something's up here I
don't know I asked a crowd about I don't
read the news I like just intentionally
get away from it for two years now so
I'll ask audiences like what's going on
in the world yeah um one of them is like
Kanye's homophone like what did he say
or not homophobic whatever the other one
the other one
but I was like what does that mean like
I think he means his agents and I was
like oh I've been saying that for many
years
they're your Jews yeah when you're upset
you like go talk to your Jews get tell
them to get you a break from the road
you know and even if they're like
they're not a Jew they're in the Jew
Arts yeah exactly
yeah
it's just like we're good at being
agents I don't know we like I'll get you
some money like sweet
you're good at that go get it you can
say it yeah exactly
it's not the worst thing in the world to
be good at making money yeah yeah I
don't think it's a bad thing yeah who's
making that a bad thing I think it's
yeah when does it get bad it gets bad
when it's like
you're organizing in a way they're
taking my money yeah yeah well that was
a funny thing
yeah
I'm alone
but that's the thing we were talking
about with a with a when it comes like
the Jews running Hollywood it's like
well they haven't exactly made
themselves Heroes right like if they do
run Hollywood where's the Jewish
superhero they're nine they're still the
villains oh you're right like Magneto is
Jewish survive the Holocaust and he's
still the bad guy wow you're right
Holocaust Survivor bad guy he's a bad
guy because he saw what about that crazy
wow like the Germans put all the cool
stuff in them so maybe there's something
you would think he would just be like
yeah yeah you think he would just be
like dude Germans yeah he's like let's
get revenge on all the way you know his
powers to control metal but is that just
like to get the money
because back then
[Laughter]
accordingly
wishing well
who is this guy he's like it's just
shitty superhero he's my lawyer actually
that's crazy that's how they got him to
unlock his powers by moving a coin yeah
that was the very first thing they made
him do holy
my buddy Paul when I was in Middle
School this kid I want to say his last
name but he was his Peruvian kid and
there was this kid Howard just [ __ ] up
but there was a kid Howard who is uh it
was his Jewish kid and what every day
during lunch we would go to Subway to
get sandwiches and Paul would put a
nickel on the middle of the table he'd
be like watch watch he's gonna go for it
he's gonna go for it just watch his
watch as well
if you ever see like like someone put a
mouse in like a in like a snake cage
yeah and he was like
yeah so so there's some I guess I don't
know real [ __ ] there I don't know I
don't think Kanye's doing anything it's
just like overhyped really yeah yeah
people like he's just as I said I was
like I'm not seeing it I don't know just
why does it become a problem for you are
you just kind of like numbed all of it
and it's not doing anything I don't know
he's not doing anything he's just like
expressing a little disinterest it's
like that's fine same memory uh my uh
Canon whatever his name is Mike Cannon
the older one who looks younger
than film specials
yeah Nick Cannon got in trouble for it
too they try to take a show like who
gives a [ __ ] he's got it he's okay
paranoia why you know they're not doing
anything yeah but it it got real bad
once this isn't that bad it's just a
celebrity saying like
follow that job
[Laughter]
can't black people will say the same
thing it got real bad once yeah
different now do you think that there is
a uh like an oppression Olympics that
black people and Jews are fighting
no foreign
yeah no way blacks are number one
Black's number one because he's tried
and then everyone was like shut up dude
no one cares about you yeah we weren't
buying it from the Asia yeah more
stories about Jews but blacks
I don't know just I guess I wonder
people write stories yeah write stories
about
Jews I don't know hey hey learn how to
write
you think blacks are wanting to pay the
Olympics Olympics
wow absolutely absolutely a wild take
that's the wildest take has ever been on
this podcast yeah I thought Katie just
said yeah run everything and he's done
but he's still here he's still fine no
he's not yes nothing's off Spotify he's
he's he's being talked about non-stop
all his money is gone
deals are done like he's done he's done
out here I just wonder I think that
that's like the amount of people hard
drive guy drops the n-word and people
celebrate him which one well that's
NASCAR though
yeah well there's not enough black
people wait wait but has anybody you've
got to have an example of somebody who
said something bad about black people
who's also done I mean Megan Kelly is
the example I always use like she asked
about blackface and then immediately she
gets kicked off the air and then gets a
new show no she has her own show no
she's doing her she produces her own
show oh she produces but it's not it's
never either way it's not easy to go
after either one I think when it's is
how many group how many of those people
are in the industry so for example like
you can't say anything about black
people and basketball because even if
black people don't own the basketball
teams they run basketball they run yeah
exactly please just don't take as many
pictures with black people
like don't even be in pictures with them
yeah that's a crazy thing that was wild
he was like you can [ __ ] them yeah
from a rich white guy old money Country
Club perspective he was saying like I
don't I'm Progressive but I'm
Progressive
Thanksgiving is like just say you're my
friend
that's fine you know I love you babe
just come on yeah yeah I know man I
think it's like uh
how many people are in the industry and
then you have to respect them and maybe
that's the idea about representation no
you know why the industry's hello Jewish
why it's because it's you have to
operate at a failure level for a while
financially and so like if you're want
to be an agent or manager you've got to
work for four it used to be 450 bucks a
week tons of overtime no overtime pay so
who can live on that you need someone
funneling you money you need a parent a
rich person funneling you money yeah we
just we had money so we're able to be
like go follow you follow your dream
is there ever like is there ever this
feeling like all right you know Akash
for example being a comedian as an
Indian he should be an engineer he
should be a doctor or whatever being in
front of the camera is that looked down
upon did you ever were your parents ever
no they just didn't think it would work
you know I'm sure for all you guys it's
like well you can't do comedy that's
like yeah a wild
celebrities in comedy no one we know
could do it you know
so that once I started making a little
money or I got my first commercial they
were like oh sweet and they're 100 yeah
oh wow yeah yeah were your parents
different though because you were raised
Orthodox you of course I had to get out
of that yeah so I'm like what was that
like we did a little research here you
found the Orthodoxy you weren't you're
like uh Born Again Orthodox yeah when I
was you little but you started out as
just regular as like conservative and
then like third fourth grade my dad's
like let's get religious again what were
you doing
oh they knew these [ __ ] hookers I was
like
so suddenly it's like oh oh hey remember
Halloween
[ __ ] try to keep a memory of it
because we don't do that anymore
that was the worst one yeah what's the
deal with that I had a Jewish friend
growing up and I wanted to do Halloween
with him and his parents were like nah
you can't that's the worst one offensive
yeah I just said dressed as a Jew like
that's perfect yeah that's scary in my
neighborhood exactly
they're coming
they're changing the neighborhood for a
better or worse they're buying up the
neighborhood
what's the Halloween thing it's Pagan
but I remember switching to a religious
school and then the teacher asking like
what some I can't guess Columbus Day she
goes what's this day and I was like you
know when you know something I was like
it's Halloween and she was like October
20 and I was like she's like no it's
Columbus Day but also we don't do that
and I was like
wait what do you mean what do you mean
she's like yeah we don't do Halloween
it's Pagan damn like what's Pages have
your own Halloween yeah right that's
great you're supposed to get drunk
religious Catholics don't do Halloween
really no Jehovah's Witness we break all
the rules it's so lame because it has
nothing to do with religion anymore
you're not actually working like you're
devil worshiping or you know but that's
Orthodoxy is um by the book by the book
yeah so you know definitely you can
choose okay so how do you get out of
that you go to Yeshiva he went to
Seminary a couple years and then
realized I didn't believe in God
just wasn't in me it's just like why do
you not like tomatoes it's just like
he's just you just think about it you're
like it's not in there but you were
reflecting there was a moment where you
were just yeah I was like oh I don't
think I believe in this
drugs no no I just I was just I wanted
to turn off a light on Shabbos once and
I didn't do it but I was worried about
people this isn't special a little bit
but like people going by my window yeah
in Jerusalem and
um and they're like I'll get in trouble
if they see my light go off but then it
just like for about a year I struggled I
was like why would I care about the
people seeing me it's not their law
God's law so he has to take that up with
me yeah I that's why I'd fear not these
people and I'm like yeah and then I'm
like maybe I don't really believe in him
like I always say like if you're jerking
off like if your dad's in the room
you're not just gonna jerk off because
he's like what are you doing but oh my
God like I didn't know you were real
like you're positive he's real you don't
do it you know but like if you weren't
sure you're like I don't know I don't
know how they say but it's not a real
thing you know it had nothing to do with
that like yeah and I just didn't believe
in it so I had to like I had to make a
hard decision to get out